sap landscapes have advanced needs for
backup storage
especially when you design high
availability and disaster recovery
in google cloud there are many options
for backup to choose from
what are these options which one is
relevant
for your sap deployment scenario or use
case
what is unique to google cloud hi
i am ramesh suar paraju and in this
video i will answer these
questions on backup strategies and
solutions for sap systems
on google cloud
[Music]
customers run mission critical business
processes
on their sap systems down times
must be kept to a minimum to ensure
business continuity
regular backup of data ensures speedy
recovery
from potential data loss google cloud
offers cost effective native
capabilities
as well as partner solutions for backup
of data
before we look at various backup options
let us look at a typical
sap deployment here is the architecture
of a sap deployment on google cloud
the application layer is a set of one or
more
sap netweaver application servers
deployed on compute engine
with associated persistent disk storage
in a specific zone
within a google cloud region the
database layer
has a single database server for sap and
is also
deployed on compute engine with
associated persistent disk storage
zooming in on the storage part of this
architecture
we can see that there are a few specific
volumes at file system level
that are relevant for backup in the
application layer
these are the virtual machine boot disk
the folders for sap mnt
and swap space at the database layer the
relevant volumes are again the boot disk
folders that contain the data and logs
of the database
and folders that hold the database
backups
google cloud recommends to separate
these
backup relevant folders from the boot
disks
into separate persistent disks
google also recommends that ssd disks
are used
especially for sap hana installations
due to their performance and throughput
requirements
hdd can be used for cost optimization
and backup purposes now let us look at
an example
of a centralized s-4hana deployment on
google cloud
when i select this deployment in the
google cloud console
and click on name of the instance we can
see
the disk layout for this deployment
here you can see the boot disk of the s4
instance
and all the other backup relevant
volumes created
and attached to the s4 instance
now let me introduce you to the backup
options
for each component of a sap installation
on google cloud
persistent disk snapshots are global
resources that offer a simple
and straightforward way for backup
cloud storage buckets offer regional
dual region and multi-regional storage
options
that can support high availability and
disaster recovery architectures
of sap installations cloud storage
also offers different storage classes
like near line cold line and archive
storage
with rule-based configuration for time
to live
and transitioning between these storage
classes
partner solutions for shared file
systems like netapp
cloud volumes also offer resilient
backup option
using cloud storage buckets
cloud file store is a cost effective
option for single zone sap installations
like sap hana scale out in a single zone
where high availability is achieved by
standby nodes
within the same zone how can these
options be used
to backup sap systems at the application
layer
you can schedule pd snapshots as backup
for disks of the sap netweaver
application server
for multi-instance installations where a
shared file storage like netapp is used
you can use the features of the shared
file solution
to backup disks to cloud storage buckets
at the database layer 2 you can schedule
snapshots
of pds in case of sap hana database
you can bypass the persistent disks for
hana backup volumes
and use backend agent for google cloud
to directly backup
to cloud storage buckets let me drill
down into the application layer
this architecture shows a multi-instance
sap network installation
with separate vms for primary and
additional application servers
as well as the central services you can
see that the snapshots
are created for each of the backup
relevant disks
like the boot disk sap mnt
and the swap space folders you can
schedule these
snapshots for automating the backup
mechanism
across your sap landscape
now let me show you how to schedule a
snapshot of a persistent disk
here you can see the existing snapshot
schedules for a centralized two-tier
deployment
of a s4 harness system where the
database
and application server are all installed
on a single server
while you can see schedules exist for
boot
swap and other disks of this deployment
a schedule for backup of hana data
is still missing let us go ahead
and see how to create one here i
navigate to the relevant persistent disk
which is called s4hana data
and see that there is no snapshot
schedule for this disk
i will proceed to edit the disk
configuration to create one
notice that you need not stop the vm
to do this once
i am in the edit mode of the disk i can
choose to create a snapshot schedule
and specify required configuration like
name description location of the
snapshot
regional or multi-regional the scheduled
frequency
and start time for taking the snapshot
i can also specify the deletion rules
in my example i want it to be 90 days
after entering all parameters i click
create
finally i save the disk configuration
the schedule to take snapshots for the
hana data disk
is now active you can check in
the snapshot schedules page that there
is now
a new schedule to backup the hana data
volume
productive sap installations often use
shared file storage in the application
layer to enable faster failover
of application servers shared file
solutions
like netapp cloud volumes also offer
configuration of snapshots
of the shared disks to google cloud
storage buckets
let me move on to the database layer if
the database server is
sap hana you have two alternatives
the first option is to create schedules
to snapshot the relevant disks
and automate a regular backup of your
database
alternative option is to use the sap
hana
backend agent for google cloud
the hana backend agent is a free of cost
software agent that can be downloaded
from google cloud
to be installed on the vm that runs
your sap hana once the backend agent is
installed
you can specify the cloud storage bucket
into which
the backup files are to be stored
you can then turn on the options for
catalog
and log backup to use the backing agent
another feature is to enable parallel
backup streams
to decrease backup times drastically
this configuration is done your sap hana
system
and databases will now use the backend
agent
to backup directly to google cloud
storage bucket
all the subsequent backups that are
triggered by your sap hana database
are directly stored in the specified
google cloud storage bucket
instead of a file system folder of a
persistent disk
in this way you can bypass the need to
provision
a persistent disk for hana backup
volumes
here you can see the storage bucket in
which the hana backup files are stored
you can see that the systems and the
tenant databases
have separate backup folders and of
course
you can restore a database directly from
its bucket location
to complete the database layer this
architecture shows
the snapshots scheduled for all backup
relevant folders
in case of any other database server
like cybase ase
or a ms sql server you can refer
to the relevant database server
documentation
for the exact location and names of the
data
log and backup folders to summarize
google cloud recommends separate disks
for backup relevant volumes of your sap
deployment
you can schedule snapshots of persistent
disks
as primary mechanism for backup of sap
systems
shared file solutions also supports
snapshots
to google cloud storage you can use
sap hana backend agent for google cloud
to bypass persistent disks for hana
backup volumes
you can find a lot more information
about backup options and solutions for
sap deployments
on google cloud at the links below this
video
also please navigate to cloud.google.com
forward slash sap
for information about other topics
related to
sap on google cloud thanks for listening
[Music]
you